[Music]
welcome back to off the record we talk
about whatever we want what's up alex so
you uh you said that you're a big fan of
kanye west he hates the new kanye album
huge fantasy huge fan i'm sorry a huge
fan i did not listen to it yeah i didn't
expect it either yeah i just you're
right you don't want to waste your time
right no i actually feel like an [ __ ]
though so i i uh i see i ain't sassy bro
he's what i'm used to with kanye is like
good high high-energy [ __ ] so i was like
okay come on go trains i i i bought uh
donda and i was gonna play it you bought
dondo yeah and as soon as it started
playing while i was training it was just
donda
donda
[ __ ] two minutes straight i'm like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] so i changed it and then
later on
and then later i read i i uh i read
about um his new album
and so the album is dedicated to his mom
and his mom's name is donda it better be
and
i think his mom and his mom passed away
at 52 or 58 or something so he says
donda 52 times and it's in the rhythm of
his mom's last heartbeat yeah so i was
like oh [ __ ] i feel so bad cause i just
that still doesn't mean we all want to
hear it i know like well that's his
artistic experience it's like
contemporary art when you walk into a
gallery and you're like what the [ __ ] i
don't care what the meaning is this
[ __ ] like he ran out of music ideas and
was like i was like oh [ __ ] i feel bad
for [ __ ] that's like that's like you
and you would do this and i love you for
it but taika spits up on the floor and
then you
cover it with a piece of glass and then
you like trace it i would [ __ ] i know
you would you [ __ ] hang it too i
would remember he was like well you
understand this is the first time he
spit up since when he was born
we don't give a [ __ ]
it's significant to you that's fantastic
yeah that was for kanye on that one that
was just for kanye that's like jacking
off and coming really good and then it
[ __ ] shoots in the air and then you
[ __ ] swallow it yourself that's a
kanye that's almost the exact same thing
that's exactly what i was trying to say
but so much
honestly he actually said it a few words
and that's very impressive brevity's the
soul whip
listen to both kanye and the drake album
the new ones
i listened to drake because i've been a
fan of drake for a while i didn't like
that one either but only one song the
new drake was no good i i wasn't a big
fan of it who rocks bro who [ __ ]
rocks who's my favorite rapper recently
do you like the takishi69 huh low key i
kinda do who's your favorite my favorite
rapper of like like
all the time asap rocky no it was back
in the day it was like easy oh he sucks
and uh
he's like do you like west coast rap the
most but no lie easy he did kind of suck
i mean he even write it he didn't he
didn't even write his raps in nwa but
that's why i didn't actually that's why
i said that yeah but the way steve's a
purist though
before i like easy too because of the
combination of the beats and the [ __ ]
that he says on it yep dude nwa back in
the day like dope man off that nwa album
that [ __ ] was so good but i really like
waka flaka um
that style of like trap music that came
from atlanta back in like
2009-10 that [ __ ] was like what kind of
like all this new rap that's out like
that you know all this same [ __ ] that
all got started from that rap music it's
an example it's hard for me to connect
with all the new stuff that's coming up
i don't even really i used to be so
involved in it because we were into rap
music back in the day and i used to be
so i knew when all the mixtapes were
coming out i remember when like chief
keef and all that [ __ ] started popping
off and yeah
i don't know the [ __ ] i had heard of his
name but i don't even know the music
chief keith used to be good but then it
was kind of like you know kanye just
after a while they're both just trash
right
[Laughter]
jesus i like conde yeah bro i like the
new album though
i mean i don't like the new album list
the recipe but i'm a big kanye fan i
wasn't go i wasn't expecting anything of
it i just was like i'm just going to see
if i like it or not and i listen through
it the whole album the whole album did
it trip you out when it goes down to it
yeah and then i was like okay but then i
i knew what the whole thing was about
so i was like yeah whatever i'm not
gonna listen to this like whatever i can
do that more than once whenever i play
that album i'm always gonna start that's
the first track i'm gonna start on track
two i'll start a track two and i'll just
never listen to the first one and that's
fine whatever but i i didn't think i was
gonna thoroughly enjoy it but i really
liked it i liked it a lot really yeah
i haven't really been listening to new
rap music that much like like i said i
used to be really involved in like when
migos were still underground that's when
they were really good you know when they
got mainstream you're kind of like all
right um i've just been listening to
like rock again because i used to be
also in a metal band when i stopped uh
[ __ ] the ladies and slanging the
dopes i left the lifestyle and the music
with the behind yeah when when you know
i just wasn't about it about it anymore
you know about that what are you [ __ ]
now
just a lady
and i'm doing the dope instead of
selling the dope so
what music do you listen to i feel like
joe doesn't listen to music he just
drives silent he listens to like
japanese trans music window's always
down never uses the ac
very close to the truth lately i've been
listening to the sound of my engine to
make sure that my transmission is
clocking in that direction
what do you train to you just turn your
car on you lift to the
train
[Music]
to 80s
um cheesy music oh it's cheesy i love it
80s like pop like the synthetic stuff
what's that one girl that there's one
hit singles from the 80s oh their albums
suck but then it's like madonna that one
girl they'd be like i need a hero oh
marty tyler bro that [ __ ] i need a [ __ ]
that's fire [ __ ] eye of the timer
i need some [ __ ] that makes me feel like
i'm van damme and i'm ready to kick
somebody oh that's not cheap that's not
cheesy dude like 80s montage music hell
yeah 80s montage music
i like steve what are you using oh bro
i'm right there she took the limit push
it to the limit yeah as he's like i like
that not the rick ross one but the
the scarf [ __ ] glasses and drinking yeah
yeah yeah montage music dude mike if
your turn hero what do you listen to oh
be careful i think i listened to uh
i i listened to podcasts oh for [ __ ]
let's play this game you're telling me
when you're cleaning your room or like
podcast time no also in it when i'm not
i do that too i i listen to low five
because i just want to go like chill out
i like that too too much i like that
but um and i'm not so when you go roller
skating you put podcasts on no i just i
just listen listen to little fighty
what's low-fi beats the study music with
the girl
is that now they have a new genre like
there's always a new genre of lo-fi
beats to anything there's like brazilian
jazz lo-fi which is pretty dope and then
there's what is like this what is local
is it like ambiance music kind of
something where you can kind of put in
the background while you just kind of
like it's like music yeah
i'll play it for you after this
i wonder what kind of idiot listens to
that kind of [ __ ] i do that when i
study or when i work probably literally
eighty percent of the audience sorry
[Laughter]
they like to study to the two different
things and like that's what those who
are not studying to just get any news or
probably listen to low-fi beats it does
actually help me focus really yeah
i feel like you listen to 90s rock like
i do i love 90s rock i love 80s rock as
well 90s you guys depressing dude
tyler's total heart is my karaoke song
yeah and i love [ __ ] kiss
yeah you know what i'm saying do you
like kiss
that's 80's and he doesn't like a lot of
music bro you might like izzy dc and
[ __ ] oh i love i love all that [ __ ] yeah
i'm down i'm down [ __ ]
honestly i never really knew anything of
kiss honestly
well i find it very hilarious most of
the time but i like the aerosmith i like
the lead zap i like the um uh guns and
roses
all that a man of [ __ ] taste i've
been on like alice in chains right now
stone temple pilots nirvana
push great era yeah that that's what
i've been freaking sad era dude audio
slave
that kind of [ __ ] yep yep
before that they were um system of a
down system of doubt sound they were
sounds like
audio slaves nobody likes
hey
get the [ __ ] out savage garden dude
savage garden garden
offspring offspring
yeah sub 41 smash mouth
hey get the [ __ ] out of here
from your own show okay i love smash
smash i'm doing this for the part that i
remember you're fired
audio slave was cool though because it
was it was uh the vocalist of
soundgarden with the band members of
rage against the machine so it was such
a good mix against machine was my
favorite band because i was such a
socialist
i was like dude in high school
you know you pl you put on [ __ ] army
fatigues you play a good rage against
machine and you're just like ready to
march against your teachers yeah best
rap song of all time in my opinion
though bombs over baghdad
outcasts i love about this our cast is
pretty dope yeah outcast is cool too do
you really see you guys did you guys
ever like limp biscuit yeah i love the
biscuit yeah as a joke in high school
the secret though
off the record i'll talk about that i
liked it chocolate fish and the hot dog
flavored water is one of my top three
albums of all time chocolate stuffing
i can't like i can't listen to it now
because it feels so like dated yeah but
in that period of time rock and hip hop
was going like this it was mind blowing
today's video is brought to you by
nutrafull and thanks to neutralfold my
foliage is full of nutrients and it's
lively and it's wonderful
and did you know that
80 million
people
men and women in the u.s experience
thinning hair it's a big problem it's
pretty crazy and you know what's awesome
now though is you could take control of
your situation and don't let it don't
let the hair get away from you let it
grow
from you
what i love about it is that it's custom
formulated by physicians with botanicals
in it and it's drug free because for me
i try not to take as much stuff as
possible so you're naturally doing it
making your hair stronger and fuller
which i like a lot but on top of the
thicker hair you get better skin nails
man bro i got nails i got claws i got
wolverine nails dude yeah it's healthy
for all that stuff but best of all
better libido like man the ingredients
in here no matter i don't know what it
is but it's got me uh thicker hair and
thicker you know
rods thicker there thicker hair there
and clinical studies neutral users were
able to experience fuller thicker hair
and less shedding in just three to six
months wow which is super cool make sure
you go to nutrifort.com and use the
promo code otr
to get 15 bucks off your first
subscription and free shipping this is
the best offer available anywhere and
it's only available to our us customers
for a limited time so there's free
shipping on every order and 15 bucks off
your first month's subscription don't
forget to go to nutrafold.com he's the
promo code otr i think that's why i was
so into both worlds because i was a huge
limp biscuit fan and raging as a machine
band so like when i was in a death corps
band all my lyrics were
all my lyrics were rap songs
so but i just had to scream them instead
of like wrap them but try to be the jack
de la roca
wrapping screamer
limp bizkit one of my after that album
though they kind of went to [ __ ] what's
the guy's name fred durst
dude he's a director now he directed a
movie a couple years ago or just like
last year and he was signed to a little
wayne's label
young money music man i thought corn
signed them
oh this guy's a big question remember
that you like horn christina aguilera
and fred durst [ __ ] or something did
they good for that one uh some shady
songs because of the eminem song
[Laughter]
i don't know how it's true you know i
blew him or something i believe so shout
out to them that's type isn't that cool
that's pride christina do you talk to
any rappers or anything do you like kind
of like
talk biz with them hey bart but don't
you dm with some rappers
how are you asking the rapper to be on a
track hey bart what's your best hide and
seek story
[Laughter]
piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
just because i don't i'd like to [ __ ]
around all the time nick knows like a
fighter will post something i'll just
straight talk [ __ ] today
i'm like quit ducking you [ __ ] [ __ ]
justin poyet right he's a very famous
fighter he just knocked out conor
mcgregor you beat him twice
he's like this dude is tran he's posting
a picture from a training and then i
scroll down and sometimes you can see
like when people like a mutual friend
likes a picture or they comment and i
see bark juan fight me then you [ __ ]
i look at it i tap on it and i'm like i
wonder how many people liked it nobody
saw it yet
so i'm the only one that likes it but it
makes me giggle every single time i
fight me you push it but it's on a lot
of different people like i just randomly
like if i get inspired i'll just write
something fight me and then i saw this
rapper talk about how he's dropping
verses or shout outs or doing whatever
everything's fifty percent off like dm
me i'm like all right i'll dm you so i
dm then i'm like how much for a verse
and it goes depends on how much you can
afford let me know and i'll bless you
with the verse and i was like that's not
the response i thought i was gonna get
to be fair the guy that posted this
didn't say serious inquiries only though
so that's why he reached out i thought i
thought did you think he was gonna say
yo i'll give you buy one get one i
thought he was gonna give me a real
price why didn't you just come back with
a price like go like yo i'll give you
guys like jewelry dude
there's no price tag on a verse like
he's not gonna be like usually it's 10
grand but for you my friend it's 499.
because you know snoop dogg it's like
widely known if you give him 10 g's
he'll do a verse anywhere so i was like
oh yeah 10 g's yeah that's what he's
like
there's no price tag on his instagram
it's like jewelry are you telling me i
could do a rap song right now and then
at the like third if you pay snoop ten
she's he'll he'll do it yeah he'll come
on the first and start counting or some
[ __ ]
one to the two
three dizzle that's all i need that's
cheap ten thousand cheese
that's why he's in every song yeah
that's true so i was like will you show
up in the music video for 20.
and just all you have to do is just do
this
do it in front of a white psyche you
don't even care
his legs don't move it's just upper body
but he did it he threw me off
so you didn't give him offer and then
the text wasn't wrapped in flames and
[ __ ] it was flaming around dude no
wonder snoops in every rap song ever of
all time he's everywhere though he's
everywhere he's still working wow that's
like shaq with every brand deal he's
like he does commercials for every
company dude he's in gold bond
commercials yeah general insurance he's
in hemorrhoids commercials yeah he's
like you guys know i got hemorrhoids
dude he's like i think he's like the
head of papa john's now isn't he is he
really papa john's he does right yeah
because the whole company he has a large
steak of popcorn they have a whole pizza
named after him really really all right
i saw that papa john's is trash i would
never know that but what kind of pizza
wait what are we talking about you get
the [ __ ] pepperoncini pete the
pepperoncini pepper in the little side
the garlic dip there yeah the garlic
like i said papa john's is trash
yeah what do you like domino's is the
best fast food pizza there oh you're
like my wife domino's is pretty good
pizza hut
p hey pizza hut though that's way better
stuff crushed pizza from pizza hut in
the minute that's pretty good round
table is that good right i've never had
it
i see it all over the place but the
round table loki is a sleeper it looks
like in arizona we had something called
peter pepper pizza it's kind of like uh
chuck e cheese that's what round table
looks like to me oh that's cool you're
gonna take a [ __ ] on uh
on one of the greatest pizza franchises
of all time then you talk about peter
piper
pewdiepie peter parker pizza the pizza
people pick is what it's called peter
pan pizza the pizza people fake
unbelievable but um
you knew you grew up in arizona yeah
dude you are from america hey but i
always heard shakey's was california's
pizza the [ __ ] hell no
combination is cool pizza with fried
chicken and the mojo potatoes that's
kind of cool and a buffet that's the
other combo yeah there's roaches that
[ __ ] run around while you're eating
yeah nobody goes to shakies anymore dude
yeah that's like especially with kovid
they're going out of business for sure
we used to go every year really people's
family loves shakies so if it's
someone's birthday you go there well
next birthday can we go can i go yeah i
want
we used to go there for jk lunches
sometimes but then we find out no one's
working after all pass the [ __ ] out yeah
everyone's looking so tired
dude next time you come to jk we're
gonna get pizza yeah i'm down peter
piper's pizza guess what if it's papa
john's i'll start no guess what i'm
gonna put papa john's in the domino's
box you go [ __ ] you're gonna love it
my mom used to always get papa john's
and we used to be like [ __ ] man i'd
rather just have like baked chicken or
something what's wrong with papa john's
it just tastes weird really like pizza
i think that's your childhood trauma bro
i think that [ __ ] yeah i remember when
it first came out though it blew my mind
because i was like this doesn't taste
like dominoes or pizza hut and it tastes
better it's gourmet yeah i didn't like
it because it was more expensive but
then i was always like i was like oh i'm
gonna i'm gonna splurge and get papa
john's have any of you guys had round
table pizza yeah i have do you like it i
don't remember because it was like
literally 15. it's pretty good man it's
pretty good there's a spot that opened
up in like west hollywood called prince
street pizza and it's almost solid yeah
he had it and it's a spot from new york
they moved out here and they brought a
new york water filter so like they
filter their water to be like it is
really good so we had it in it that [ __ ]
right and it's like focaccia style so
it's like it's not like a for that no
hate it's like this thick yeah dude
you know what's pretty good uh bj's
like dj it's fluffy that's the fluffy
stuff
it's good because it's like i like that
deep dish oh you like the thick fluffy
kind
it's crispy in the [ __ ] bottom yeah i
like the i want the texture you know i
mean i want a little i want a little
crunch a little soft i want to bite into
a butt cheek like
you'll like prince street then okay
try that i had new york cheesecake and i
was like this is just gonna be whatever
i've had cheesecake no no new york
cheesecake in new york is amazing where
did you go to get it i went to um this
steakhouse over there called the camera
restarts the g but it's really famous
and really [ __ ] good like amazing
like melts in your mouth like everything
all the hype you hear [ __ ] stuff
about new york cheesecake in new york is
real it's not gaucho grill
no no
[Laughter]
was it peter lugers
gallagher's
gallagher's
watermelon
silence it yeah really good it was a
good night too me and nicky were there i
flew out to new york to see eminem at
the youtube music awards
and then we went to the steakhouse
afterward and like the owner came to our
table and he's like oh he's like i hope
you're having a good experience and it
was just great i like when they do that
yeah i love that [ __ ]
they make you feel important and [ __ ]
like you're a celebrity yep
that's classy
have you guys ever used that opportunity
to complain about their food and be like
actually the asparagus
that's so good
and then this
i don't know
you can play like that
i don't know
i couldn't i wish i could i'm such a
[ __ ] that when the when i'm confronted
by the chef
i convinced myself that the food was
good even if it was bad
because he must know more than me so i
go oh you know it was great it was
[ __ ] awesome and then months later i
go back in retrospect and go you know
what i think i was [ __ ] over dude
i think i think that food sucked that's
what happened when we went to our first
three-star michelin restaurant we paid
like 200 something a person and i was
convinced that that was great food and
then as months went by i was like man
i think
i have my own opinion about it now and
it sucks you have to go back and test it
we gotta go back and see what i never i
don't have to go but i never complain
though [ __ ] that [ __ ] even if it's bad i
just won't it has to be don't go back is
what it is after wolfgang steakhouse
that's what it was
new york
no no wolfgang steakhouse in new york
it's [ __ ] incredible
and this is where we were it has this
like subway tile ceiling and [ __ ]
that's pretty tough
yo that looks like one of those tuxedo
places man where you dress up to present
yourself to the food you can't wear no
tank top i just wore a snap up but it
worked out wow you want to impress the
steak that comes out exactly right they
have one in la but it's not nearly as
good
because you want the mashed potatoes to
look at you and go whoa look at that
[ __ ] blazer dude
expensive steak i've had it was like 25
bucks from sizzler
the most expensive ever and you're
talking [ __ ] about kanye
i had your back for a minute but you're
not a man of [ __ ] class that's over
free papa john's kanye papa john's kanye
probably papa john's they're probably
one together
they're both trash
kanye could make a stick out of you bro
i i did see him at a restaurant that
recently kanye made oh yeah he saw kanye
at a restaurant i saw connie in a
restaurant say this sooner mike i was um
i was in the arts district and uh at
this place eating how long ago was this
this was maybe about a month ago what
what say this at the beginning of this
we're on time mike it's over the video's
over oh god you know hurry up tell your
story and so like basically you know
there weren't a lot of people in the bar
and so we're all sitting by the sushi
bar right and all of a sudden uh my
girlfriend turns to me and goes wait
isn't that person there they look famous
they look famous and then so i look over
there right and i'm like oh [ __ ] wait
that's kanye right and obviously
everyone in the um the sushi bar is
probably looking in the same direction
but trying not to yeah and he probably
picked this restaurant because there's
not a lot of people inside it right and
so this is a sushi spot this is a sushi
spot in the arts district and um
so what happens is like we all notice
that like no one's getting served except
for the people who are sitting over
there and um i'm also thinking like is
it him is it not him because he's not
rolling super deep like he has like two
people with him right and they don't
even look that big and so i'm thinking
they're not like his bodyguards or
anything right and um so you know we're
eating and not really eating because no
one's getting served and then eventually
we finish our food so i go outside my
girlfriend goes to the bathroom and it's
basically you know i'm like well i'll
meet you outside and
while you know i'm she's coming outside
to meet me connie and his group they
finish and um
i notice at this point that like one guy
gets up
connie stands up and is like immediately
trying to put on his hood you know
trying to like hide himself and then the
other guy stands up behind him and so
then i realized that oh they're clearly
his bodyguards right at this point but
they look small to you they look small
little shrimps
they were they were like normal sized
people and uh basically they all run out
into this uh mercedes-benz sprinter van
that has all the windows blacked out and
basically kind of run into it and uh
right in front of the um the restaurant
it's like a no parking zone but
obviously they're parked there and so
they all run to the van and just like
speeds off and so like at that point you
know i knew it's him but i was just like
where's his posse
he doesn't usually roll deep maybe he
just wanted a private sushi experience
that's what i was thinking too and um i
was also thinking like should i go ask
for a photo or should i try to take a
photo of my girlfriend and you know kind
of oh mike but i decided not to in the
end because um i wanted to let him enjoy
that's fine i would have been away from
music i love lo-fi
i'm not a fan at all i didn't do it
forever
i i didn't do it and i don't have that
evidence and uh
hmm